just being a conservative make you a
better journalist absolutely not being a
libertarian make you a better journalist
yeah I'm here with Andrew Carell and
noah rothman they're two editors at
media it-it's Dan Abrams super-sexy
media venture and they write about
things that are smart and happening and
very very new so what the hell is media
and one sentence or less describe it
it's the intersection of politics and
media or it's or chronicle of blowhards
Chronicle blowhards I like that I agree
we Chronicle and sometimes we blowhard
it's very good we blow our the way to
play so discuss the growth and strength
of media I why are you guys growing when
so many outlets are floundering well
we're able to package a lot of content
in very small packages for for people
who don't want to sit in front of the
television all day and consume media and
we get to give you exactly what you want
little tiny bits but we also have a
variety of partisan authors who are very
strongly partisan and attract very
strong partisan people to debate each
other so I think we provide a big a good
forum what is new about new media and
how is media doing new media better well
what's new about is that we're sort of
taking down the old media the ivory
tower media people who you know the
stuffy old journalism that has a lot of
rules and there has to be a certain
format to how you report something
whereas for us it's we are all openly
partisan and you know where our views
are because each of us have written
opinion pieces but we also report on
things that are going on we don't we
don't have the pretense of objectivity
we don't we and we utilize social media
and we and I think of what's a lot
different than old media is that were
packaging things like you said in
smaller packages isn't there some
usefulness to objectivity when you're
reporting there is no such thing as
objectivity I would argue that
objectivity is dead and we should get
over that it's never existed there's no
such thing as
and I think that we are sort of and not
to fluff ourselves but we are we are so
we sort of we give up we we don't have
that pretense we don't we I'm a
libertarian he's conservative we have a
hard left winger Tommy Christopher and
we have a bunch of other default New
York liberals who just they generally
see things from a liberal point of view
we can still exception with that there
is always going to be a market for
legacy media there's always going to be
a market for real reporting straight
reporting that takes days even months
and real sourcing and and that has to be
objective to a certain extent there's
always a bias in the reporter and that's
sort of our job is to identify that
reporter is biased by knowing their work
and being able to identify patterns and
their work and patterns of behavior and
that just kind of has clarity to the to
the work but that doesn't take away from
its value as an objective report does
being a conservative make you a better
journalist absolutely not being a
libertarian make you a better journalist
yeah a lot of people say that new media
is parasitic at worst and symbiotic at
best is that true of you guys and if so
is it a bad thing if you go to the
homepage of media you get to see the
partisan take on the single issue right
next to each other in the headlines and
that's shorthand that a lot of people
can use to navigate political arguments
when they don't really have a whole
depth and breadth of knowledge on these
issues they can go to a bar and they can
say oh I saw two headlines I know
exactly what the counter-argument is to
this piece and then be able to have what
is you know kind of a faux areokay
conversation about politics and not
necessarily have to read all that much
so we package we do politics for you
there's always gonna be market for that
so if God were to reach his beautiful
beautiful hand down to earth and unplug
cable news and no more CNN no more Fox
no more NBC MSNBC and no more NBC CBS no
more of any of that no more cable news
although they're broadcast but no more
cable news would we die out I don't
actually think so I don't think we're
parasitic on cable news I think that
Chris Matthews and Sean Hannity those
people will always find an outlet so
it'll just be the web you know the Chris
Matthews will find a computer and bang
on a little bit try to figure out how to
work it and then he'll he'll get on TV
hello it on TV will be on the web so if
they unplug new media do you think the
cable news
networks would die are they parasitic of
you they get 3pr from us but I don't a
to depend let me babysit it's a great
point you shouldn't downplay Bethan that
works like current for example I mean we
have a much broader viewership than they
they need us to live MSNBC to a lesser
extent blocks locks but not so much but
those guys you know we can actually
compete on a certain level for so we
kind of have to live with each other
all right well Andrew Corral noah
rothman thank you very much media i
check it out right now here's a link for
recent TV I'm Kennedy did we actually
make a whole bunch of dick references I
trust you added up all this